remember that if you want to get on your
nickname in the waiting Lobby should be
your name and your town city or town
country even if it's something other
than the United States where you're
calling from let's go next to Joseph
from Oregon Joseph welcome
hi David thanks for taking my call
um it may be too soon to tell uh but I'm
interested in what you think the results
of the midterms could mean for Trump
from a legal perspective if cons if
conservatives are suddenly ready to jump
ship for DeSantis do you think he could
finally see a courtroom I don't think I
think the answer is Trump could see a
courtroom I don't really think the
midterms are the defining Factor though
and I'll tell you why
many of the investigations have nothing
to do with the midterms in the sense
that they are state level elections and
then when it comes to the federal
election Joe Biden Remains the president
I'm sorry the federal investigation Joe
Biden Remains the president Merritt
Garland Remains the attorney general and
Merrick Garland made it clear whether
Trump is or isn't running and whatever
happens in the election it does not
impact how we are going to carry out the
investigation and I believe them to a
degree anyway so I actually think that
Trump may think the course of the
midterms and his potential announcement
on Tuesday will change the course of the
investigations but I don't believe that
they will
awesome well thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure great to hear
from you folks something about the calls
this week very very strong I I have to
tell you I'm liking it let's go next to
Steve from Illinois Steve welcome to the
program
Steve
oh
Steve
hello
all right you know I'm just I'm just
learning how uh Discord Works uh yeah so
we've got a couple of issues it sounds
like you're using speakerphone we're
also hearing all of your Discord
notifications so we've got a few
different things what's on your mind
today
you know what I I really just wanted to
jump in and listen to this conversation
and see how you know I was
um
woke up this morning with uh better news
than I thought I would see
um so uh really I'm just kind of taking
in anything like um
you know can get my hands on and
literally this is my first time ever
using Discord so I really apologize no
problem Steve listen let me put you back
on hold so you can continue listening to
the conversation I really appreciate
that let's go I I don't know if this is
Austin from Louisiana or Louisiana from
Austin which which is your name and
which is your location
uh I am my name is Austin I am from
Louisiana North Louisiana got it got it
what's on your mind I just wanted to
come in and say that I was very
disappointed with my state I was really
hoping that uh Gary Chambers would get a
larger amount of the vote yeah it's very
it's very unfortunate what happened I
went and did my civic duty for the first
time I went and voted for the first time
I'm very happy about it but very not
happy with the results but yeah I didn't
really expect anything different and for
people who may or may not know the race
uh for Senate in Louisiana the incumbent
John Kennedy Republican won with about
62 percent of the vote Gary Chambers
just under 18 of the vote which is
certainly a disappointment but also not
altogether shocking I have to say
well it also has to do with the vote
being split between the two big
Democrats yes the the other Democrat had
like 12 or so right
yep yep not so good but voting was fine
did you have long lines did you have any
armed people intimidating you or
anything no I I live in a I live in a
white suburb so okay no risks there yeah
no it's it's horrifying that that that
explains it though okay so it was fine
then uh but such is the reality
unfortunately unfortunately all right
that's all thank you all right thanks
very much for the call I appreciate that
uh why don't we go
um why don't we go next
to wasif from is it is it from
Bangladesh
yes hello can you hear me I can hear you
fine we'll see
oh boy hello can you hear me I can hear
you there is a very strange uh sort of
digital noise I don't know where that's
coming from
oh actually I mean uh you know a
university dormitory so you know you
will hear some noise I guess I gotcha is
there like a party going on in the
background oh
not really a you know a lot of people
are actually in this dormitory that's
why you know the population is higher oh
my gosh okay people are studying I'm
sure it's only studying there thank you
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
okay so my question question is actually
related to a recent U.S foreign policy
you could say uh it's also related to my
country okay and that's why I wanted to
talk with you about it so
you guys know about the rohingya crisis
right yes that the you know a lot of
growing up refugees are in my country
right yes yes so originally rohingyas
are from the rakhine state of you know
uh Myanmar right so what's happening is
right now my country is actually facing
a big Colonial crisis obviously playing
a part of it and the other reason is the
establishment has some underlings who
are actually very corrupt and they have
you know done some terrible stuff with
our uh dollar Reserve basically so we
so what have what happened is that we
are you know uh very short on dollar
reserve and we are you know our
government is asking for you know if
bailouts and you know
potentially taking money from China and
not you know both of them are not really
you know being you know as good enough
as they expected it to be so we are
having a crisis and you know the banks
are not being able to open new LCS so
the price of let's say uh uh raw
materials for you know making medicine
and electronics are you know going high
yeah so during this situation so you
know like we are asked King U.S
for help right so what their you know
giving us salvation the what they are
providing is that they are going to give
us you know some mental support and
something like that but they really want
to want us to do something so so what
they're saying is
I I hate to interrupt we're safe but
we're the audio is a disaster I'm not
super familiar with what you're asking
me and I'm wondering if there is a
question coming I just don't know that
I'm the right person to answer it
ah
hello I get it I'll try to end it as
soon as possible I'll try to end it as
soon as possible like one or two
sentences okay so U.S basically wants us
to
so the U.S government basically wants us
to Annex Iraq and state and you know go
go go to a war against me and Mark
that's that's what I'm saying so my
question is like right at this point
when you know the US is basically
calling out Russia for you know annexing
all these four different regions yeah
Ukraine right and they are doing the
complete opposite and you know telling
us to do the same thing that what Russia
is doing right now do you think I think
you know this is a really a good moral
ground if this this kind of news no
you're you know we'll see if you're
you're exposing and how people get
American foreign policy is basically
what's useful right now I don't even
know if the things you told me are
accurate representations of what's going
on I just don't know enough about the
situation but if it were true the US is
hypocritical on foreign policy all the
time I just can't I don't even know if
what you're telling me is the case
because I've I've just I just don't know
enough about it okay well see thank you
for the call let's take a very quick
break
I I don't I just I'm not commenting on
what he said because I don't know if
it's true like the U.S is demanding that
Bangladesh do annexation I just I've not
heard that I don't know if that's true
let's take a quick break we're gonna go
back to the phones in a moment stay with
us